l'ukraine quadrillée par les russes
nous sommes parmi les tous premiers
journalistes occidentaux à y entrer
c'est l'armée russe qui nous
accompagnent elle veut nous montrer la
vie qui reprend
verdienne sq est tombé au début de
l'offensive russe sur les bâtiments
officiels
le drapeau russe et ce jour là pour la
toute première fois depuis février des
mariages sont célébrés
six couples à la fois certains ont passé
une partie de leur vie en russie
acceptez-vous de prendre maxime pour
époux oui acceptez-vous de prendre
rihanna pour épouse oui
l'hymne russe retenti
pour clore une cérémonie où il y avait
plus de journalistes que d'inviter
alors
ça roule
on est heureux très heureux
c'est une journée très importante pour
la ville
et pour nous et pour nous et on espère
pour le pays
quel pays
faux la russie ces unions ont été
célébrées selon la loi russe
un exemple de la russification en cours
dans le sud de l'ukraine
dans chaque ville la russie désigne des
chefs locaux qu'elle présente à la
presse leur feuille de route est claire
pour l'instant c'est une administration
civile militaire notre avenir nous le
voyons avec la russie amélie topol plus
à l'ouest juste après l'arrivée des
russes il y avait eu des protestations
désormais la place centrale est
sévèrement gardée des canaux militaire
joue des chansons patriotiques
drapeau rouge et célébration des
vétérans de la deuxième guerre mondiale
tout l'héritage soviétique et convoquer
un héritage qui parle à cette retraitée
je suis venu avec un drapeau rouge pour
que la russie soit victorieuse je n'ai
peur de rien parce que nous vivions bien
avec la russie mais un peu à l'écart
d'autres partagent leur désarroi à demi
mot
les prix sont élevés ils ont mis un
nouveau drapeau avant c'était notre
drapeau ukrainien sinon il y à des
militaires ici en permanence pas les
nôtres
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ce que l'on pense c'est difficile de
dire ce qu'on pense en d'autres temps va
dire ça comme ça
dans marioupol dévastée l'armée veut
nous montrer une distribution dead les
cartons sont frappés du z de l'opération
militaire russe une aide qui n'apaise
pas les désaccords dans la population
tout avait bien tout marchait bien chez
nous tout a été détruit ne racontaient
pas n'importe quoi madame ne racontez
pas n'importe quoi elle est venue ici
pour provoquer pourquoi tu es venu
chercher de l'aide humanitaire ihh si tu
es venu pour un ukrainien qu'est ce que
tu racontes ici à côté un militaire
essaie de calmer le jeu avec des
habitants excédés d'attendre le lourd et
l'électricité mais il faut d'abord
timides ou en montrant qu'ils
administrent seville les russes
cherchent aussi à rendre irréversible
processus d'intégration de ces régions
dans la fédération de russie